one last question suppose Lord Russell
this film were to be looked at by our
descendants like a Dead Sea scroll in a
thousand years time what would you think
it's worth telling that generation about
the life you've lived and the lessons
you learned from it
I would like to say two things one
intellectual and one moral the
intellectual thing I should want to say
to them is this
when you are studying any matter or
considering any philosophy
ask yourself only what are the facts and
what is the truth to the facts bear out
never let yourself be diverted either by
what you wish to believe or by what you
think could have been efficient social
effect Civic where we lived but look
only and surely and what are the factors
that is the intellectual thing that I
should wish to say the moral dignity
wish to say to them is fairly simple I
should say love is wise hatred is
foolish
in this world which is getting more and
more closely interconnected we have to
learn to tolerate each other we have to
learn to put up with the fact that some
people say things that we don't like we
don't live together in that way if we
are to live together and not die
together we must learn kind of charity
and kind of tolerance which is
absolutely vital to the continuation of
human life on this planet
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
[Music]